[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are exploring the question
are we our true selves on screen is the
rhett and Link that you're seeing and
hearing right hearing right now the real
rhett and Link or some creation designed
for your entertainment much less on GMM
or like any other screen that you may
see us on yeah I think I think it's
gonna to get me some psychoanalysis
going on here perhaps I've got some
juicy questions for the two of us to get
into I and this conversation is inspired
by a video that we made where we were
asking each other questions recently
we'll get into the details later but
there was but I'm not gonna say we had a
disagreement afterward but we had a
there are there's a few times where
we'll do a video or do have a
conversation on camera and then
off-camera we'll talk about it and I
just thought that that conversation that
we that we didn't monetize we should
monetize he's basically oh the off
camera got off camera analysis of the on
camera conversation has led to this
conversation I'll give all the the
background when we get to it but let's
let's start let's start in a lighter
place anywhere you want to go I don't
know I so I know I got a text from my
friend Ralph who little I told the story
of our skiing misadventures and how he
had led me to the top of the mountain
and then I left you for dead trouble
getting down I don't know just listen to
whatever episode that was one of the
recent ones and he was funny because
well in just as a sidebar you can say
what oh yeah blondie I saw I was telling
Rhett I saw a blond bean who was my
spartan race partner for the first time
since the race this morning because we
go to the gym at different times and
we're not
train for Spartan race anymore and
Christi had shared the podcast with her
and so she said I I will never hear my
name the same again after your friend
kept saying it and I was like blonde
bangs like ruined her own name and
another guy was saying I was like he was
listening I was like yeah it's like when
Rhett heard that her name was blonde
Dean he like made me feel weird about
seeing an old blonde Dean let's just
it's literally my favorite name I've
ever heard I love it but anyway and then
Ralph text me she enjoyed the podcast by
the way sorry sharing your biscuits with
her well that raisin family that is the
interesting thing we talk about people
so that we can increase our listenership
okay that's that's one way one one
person at a time one victim there is
this interesting dynamic of when someone
is talked about okay as another example
of this if we recently told the story of
the pooping in the Tupperware oh yeah
and then our boys who were present for
that right started the text thread and
they're like oh here we go again every
time you guys tell this story we have to
let relive it and also tell you guys all
the details that you get wrong yeah and
the one getting right that you used to
get wrong and the ones that you got
right to now you getting wrong which is
just the psychological concept of
revisiting a memory and rewriting it
every time it's just the way humans work
but they did clarify one thing that I'll
clarify now and that is that Greg wasn't
even there howdy I think we had always
said that Greg was there I don't and
somehow I don't even know Greg wasn't
there so sorry Greg for being thrown
under the bus all these years I'm
pooping in that Tupperware that you
didn't poop in but as is the case with
Ralph when he texted me he was just
laughing about how he listened to the
thing and he texted in quotes Ralph with
the next Galatian point because there's
the moment in Destroy where I yell out
his name yeah and then his son had taken
that moment and cut it into this just
basically he made a super cut of Ralph's
it was just me saying
Ralph Ralph
ralphe ralphe ralphe ralphe video or
just audio video yeah nice and so Ralph
sent that to me so every time we talk
about somebody there is the if they
listen then you have to kind of deal
with the forever they think and the
Supercuts of you saying their name
yeah our friendship matrix is crumbling
I think is another way to put which
leads me to the story that I want to
tell you because Ralph
Rock did also text me said what about
the waiter story I was like oh you
didn't uh you didn't tell the waiter
story I didn't tell anything about the
waiter we okay so we were in Mammoth
like I said and we had been to Mammoth
with this exact same family before the
year before Ralph his wife and kids and
so last year we went to well I'm trying
to think of the best way to tell this
story okay autumn you could do before we
do know I like to pull out of my butt as
I go that's fine yeah so I've tried
there's two parts to it and I don't know
which parts better but I think it's
better to start with part two and then
tell you how to release the part you
know what just do it and then Ralph's
son will get it in the best way later
and send it to his dad so well here's
what we're eating at this restaurant
relatively new restaurant in Mammoth and
we're all sitting and it's a big group
there's four of us in our family there's
five of them that makes nine and so
we're all sitting at this table and you
know the situation where you're in the
middle of a conversation and a waiter
approaches the table and they're kind of
hovering there's a little bit of a power
play that happens and some waiters are
better at managing this situation than
the others and there's also people
interestingly I think this might even
play into our conversations of who's
what we're like in real life
as an example if you're telling if
you're in the middle of saying something
in real life and a waiter comes up
chances that you stop for the waiter are
pretty small if I'm selling something in
a waiter comes up chances are pretty
high that I'm going to stop that's
just--that's
that's you may think that's the opposite
of the way it would be but in real life
that's actually it might because you
don't notice but you're also going to be
like I'm gonna get this thought out and
then there'll be a break in this this
guy can can say but so somebody else was
talking and didn't see this waiter
standing there and he stood there and he
just started going like making a mouth
noise he tunes I was like this is his
warning system it was awkward
and eventually the conversation came to
a close and he stood there made one last
mouth smacking noise and then paused
it's weird and uncomfortable and then
said hello folks how are you today and
then proceeded to do the normal waiter
things but in a way that his energy made
me feel and everyone else feel
uncomfortable it was just like it was an
animosity no no it was not an animosity
at all it was just a weirdness it was a
social okay weirdness that just made us
feel strange and like just pausing at
certain times and then like staying in
one place and then not leaving early
enough after you let you finish the
sentence it was like everything was a
little bit off time in a way that just
makes you feel uncomfortable and uneasy
so he has this interaction with us and
then he leaves and everybody's kind of
like the house kind of weird and then I
was like I'm gonna change his name
because I because item Utley don't want
this guy to listen to this podcast call
him Justin Justin what if his name was
Justin and I suggested it let's not call
him Justin I was like our waiters name
is Justin what okay you just said what
the waiters name you knew the waiters
real name which isn't Jenny I said I
said it last year at a different
restaurant we had this exact same
experience and exact same conversation
did they remember and everybody started
being like oh you're right that is the
same guy the same haircut and the
mustache and like is
same guy it's Justin and he proceeds to
do exactly the same thing that he did
the first time which we got such a kick
out of it the first time around like
this guy was so awkward in the in the
way he would pause and the way he would
sit at your table stay at your table and
then like imagine just you're taking
somebody's order and then as you get
done you're like is there anything else
you need and you're like no Penny's just
like it's like a robot download for
seconds his next line makes you feel
weird like what's going on and then he
did it again his technique new
restaurant same technique and you think
he got fired from the other place for
his pauses and whatnot no because first
of all I was like he came back and I was
like Justin right he was like yeah I was
like I remember you
you're weird waitering I said last year
you were our waiter last year at blah
blah blah a restaurant in Mammoth and he
said oh yeah I don't miss that place and
okay I don't know what happened I'm not
gonna ask any questions but it was just
it was a it was just one of those
moments that like this guy left this he
didn't remember indelible mark on us and
then he did it again and we realized
deja vu way it was happening at the same
time they're like no it's just the same
guy happening at a different restaurant
and what he says what he does in the
moral of the story no there doesn't have
to be a moral but here's the freak
here's the freaky thing it reminds me of
a story I didn't tell you but from Cabo
which is very sort it's not shortened is
not much a storied waiter well you know
as I explained I went back to the same
we went back to the same resort that we
had gone to like a couple of years
actually it may have been three years
earlier the more I thought about it okay
and they had there's a restaurant at the
Cape and the first night we were there
both times we made a reservation here
because this is really nice it's a
really good restaurant and we went there
and we sat they were going to see this
and I was like can you see this outside
there
thinking it was great that's what we did
last time we go we sit outside and then
all of a sudden the waiter comes up and
he's like asking said we've been here
we're like yes and we like you know he
we get our waters he goes away and I'm
like Christie that is the same waiter
from three years ago same guy and then
he comes back up and we're like we're
looking at him before we say anything he
was like you've been here before and he
remembered us but he wasn't weird at all
he just gained some weight I look
different I'm gonna keep this going
because your story reminds me of another
small story from my recent trip to Cabo
what can we do hey this is a whole new
way to do a whole pie yes that reminds
me what's your story that's not that
great that I'm gonna do this one's good
okay but before you tell it I want to
say that like we felt a special
connection with this guy like our first
night in Cabo our first time it was like
it kind of made the evening that like
you oh and he said I remember you cuz it
was my first day what of working him
better and like so we were special to
him he was special to us
the food was the whole thing was this is
my last day uh no that didn't happen no
we were like when do you when do you
when are you off the clock you wanna
hang we invited him up to our room we
all got in the bathtub together
it was very special I don't know why I
didn't mention it before Yeah right very
special ok we'll skip that last part so
full service there at the resort I go to
a I go to a restaurant at the resort on
the first night and it's the restaurant
at you know like the main restaurant and
we get this waiter and I mean he's a
good waiter nothing he's not weird
nothing particularly knodel notable
about him but we order you know to like
each order a cocktail then we order two
appetizers and then we each order an
entree and then we each order when you
order two desserts okay this is a pretty
complex order we stay at the resort for
three days the last night we go back to
the restaurant and we get the same
waiter he says oh you're back like yeah
I mean this is the resort but the
this is the restaurant at the resort
yeah full circle and then he's kind of
trapped here he said I how's your stay
or whatever he was like I can tell you
what you ordered the other night and he
went through every single item and was
right and you were like I'll take none
of that cuz I've already had it and I
said well we want to get completely
different things this time I'm gonna but
there's a through-line with all these
stories it's like that's interesting it
is interesting when it's happening but
then when you retell it I'm just gonna
be honest like the more I thought about
it oh no no you went to a place in
Mammoth you were served by waiter you
went to another place he moved
restaurants I went to a place three
years later it's not unheard of that a
waiter would still be working at a place
three years later and it's not unheard
of a few days later that even cut the
whole order know he would remember how
it did you did you make him go through
it
yes okay I think it's a party trick he
was like I can tell you what you had and
he went through everything cocktails
well maybe that's the more impressive
but on three story it's one thing to be
one of those waiters who remembers your
order and doesn't write it down which
always makes me nervous by the way but
this guy remembered the order from three
days before he's got multiple customers
at night
yeah that's grace that that that well
that's he should be like on a math team
that's pretty impressed a memory team
you shouldn't be a waiter that justifies
the rabbit trail we've just gone down
I'll say that okay we are gonna nut
we're not gonna talk about waiters
anymore but hold on I just remembered
yeah we did experience another waiter
that remembered us one time when we went
somewhere
remember he remembered us what we was
Stevie we were like traveling and it we
were freaking out
well so the way we're gonna win a waiter
remember she's a fourth-story they
doesn't really but then when you tell it
it's kind of like I think all our stores
are great it's you had to be there kind
of thing that's a great podcast we're
gonna tell you stories that you'd really
have to be there to appreciate we're
gonna talk about whether or not we are
our true selves on-screen but first
we're gonna let you know that link is
wearing a shirt from our story
we're collection yeah the
post-apocalypse that's right in a
post-apocalyptic world dogs take over
because humans are relegated as pets I
ain't complaining and there's a whole
series there's a whole collection
there's multiple shirts that are
t-shirts
there's your sweat pants there's a
bandanna button-up shirt there's a
bandana what else is there there's a
denim shirt a denim well you got a
button it check it out you got a button
it bandanas every every item tells the
story complete your story with story
where that mythical dot store okay so
here's how I want to set this up if you
don't know we got this thing called the
mythical Society it is a secret society
a mythical society calm check it out
we're doing vlogs over there one a month
exclusive where we're talking directly
to the society members but one of the
things that we did was we got questions
suggestions for questions submitted that
we would ask each other and one of those
questions that was asked for you to ask
me just led to and I haven't watched the
vlog back I mean you can watch it
yourself but and well unpack it a little
bit but it kind of led to a conversation
that led to a post conversation meaning
a second conversation off-camera after
that conversation well we you know I
just thought there were there were some
emotions that bubbled to the surface
that I just thought it would be
interesting for us to talk about so here
was the question they asked Rhett Rhett
can you ask link to act can you ask
cotton candy Randy to be nicer to link
right and that was the question that
hold on that you asked me right I know I
asked you that I asked you that question
and then you started to answer it and
then I was like and you were like what
do you think about it I think that's how
it went well regardless I can't member
who asks who the question but it was a
fan wanted cotton candy Randy
to be nicer to link and we do I don't
know whether that person was just asking
a joke question or if they were serious
but I don't so that specific person I
don't know don't know what they were
going for but for me that made me think
about the fact that I do see first of
all we already know that like the
Concannon Randi is very polarizing
because he said he's a negative energy
there's just some people who are into
that and you know there's a lot of
people who don't like him and there's
people who really really like him in
fact there are lots people who of all
the things that we've ever done comedic
ly in the world of good mythical morning
cotton candy Randi is their favorite
thing because it's the most subversive
thing that well one of the most first of
things that we've done it kind of goes
against type that we've established on
GMM in a lot of ways so a lot of people
just that's their thing and they really
like it yeah he's a twisted and demented
character whose head and facial hair is
made out of cotton candy and when kids
eat too much candy he's gonna show up
and whisper sweet nothings in their ear
meaning he is going to terrorize them
throughout their sleep cycle and he's
like an anti tooth fairy and he one
notable thing about him is he really
dislikes you yeah the bit he really
likes you
is that he well he likes to whisper
things to me and I regardless of how
demented they are always seem to enjoy
and really enjoy and then you he always
says very mean things to you and
apparently he wants you dead I mean
that's yeah I think that's it that's
Rick cotton candy Randy in a nutshell
and I thought this was an opportunity
like what I was doing at the time is I
was like you know this is inside
conversation mythical society that's one
of the things it's about is like let's
have a conversation that we wouldn't
necessarily have elsewhere probably on
your biscuits maybe but anyway so I said
what I was trying to do is I was trying
to set you up so that you could say what
I want to hear because you know me I'm
the horse love cotton candy Randy I like
subversive things that kind of comedy
really appeals to me and
get legitimately annoyed with people who
have a problem with him now I don't
expect there's nothing wrong with you if
you don't like him and I know in comedy
is incredibly polarizing and I don't
expect everybody to like him and in fact
one of the reasons I do like him is
because I know that people don't like
him that's how my brain works but there
may be something so there's nothing
wrong with respecting someone else's
comedic opinion of cotton-candy Randy
but there may be something wrong and
well there may be another thing that
you're taking issue with which is a
misunderstanding of what's going on the
thing that you did was you you asked me
the question you kind of threw the ball
to me you were like so what what would
you say to that linked to you like do
you think that's a good idea whatever
and I was like well I think that would
be silly to ask
cotton-candy Randy to be nice to me
because cotton-candy Randy is a
character but and the reason why we
didn't we interpret that way that
someone was asking it sincerely is
because there are a lot of seemingly
sincere comments online I think you see
them a lot more than I do because they
maybe I don't know why if you're looking
for more if they at you but not me or
something or maybe I just don't read
them but because another way to
interpret it was it would be a funny bit
if you asked cotton candy Rainey to be
nice to link which maybe that might be a
good choice that may be a good
suggestion but I'm pretty sure that's
not what was behind the question and
what it kind of led to for me was okay
obviously there is a certain dynamic
between the two of us and we kind of and
this is why we're having this
conversation because it plays into the
greater question that we're asking today
which is are we our true selves on
camera there's a in the comedic duo of
who we are there is a certain dynamic
where you kind of play this role where
you are if we're gonna do a bit that's
on brand or according to type yeah I
think if the show is doing a prank it's
probably going to be done on you right
like if we're gonna have a pill that
makes you lose the ability to taste
I see foods like we did that one episode
well it's probably gonna be the most
true to type if I'm in the know and you
don't know and we're playing the prank
on you right and so that's just now
first obviously we can do it the
opposite way and it goes against type
and it's funny for a different reason
but also if we have a character like
cotton candy Randy and this wasn't a
discussion nobody ever discussed this
like Jordan invented cotton candy Randy
yeah I never said he's gonna like how he
was mad I'm gonna hate link but as he
entered into the dynamic of rhett and
Link his natural sort of comedic
inclination was that wouldn't it be
funny if I just hated link and whispered
weird things to Rhett
and so there's enough of that kind of
thing that has happened over the years
that there is a segment of the mythical
beasts who are like why you got to be
picking on link why do you why is link
the butt of so many jokes right and so
what I was asking you to do as from a
cut from a comedy stamp yes is to
basically say hey guys that's that's
part of our comedy and you shouldn't
feel sorry for me right so right as a
side note I think that the the spicy
pill prank that was played on me was a
bad example and we should come back to
it so let's let's not forget to come
back to that because I think that that's
that doesn't work but it will you know
it's a good enough work in this context
it doesn't prove your point once we get
it once we analyze it later good but the
cotton candy or anything there's a gut I
mean it's obviously Jordan or if you
don't know Jordan somebody who's it's
not a dude is his it's a fake beard
made out of cotton candy it is a carrot
guy he's not a real so we we've entered
this mode where it's it's it's it's not
scripted it's totally improv but it's
we're not being ourselves we're just
plain weird
we're playing things for comedic effect
entirely so but but the thing that I
found interesting was even though I gave
the right answer it wasn't it was it was
a little bit different than what you
were looking for and that's fine but I
think it's fascinating so that's the
only reason I want to talk
about it because I said my answer was
well if you ask cotton candy Randy to be
nice to me I think I think that's a
silly request because obviously the
comedy is in and this is me talking then
the comedy is in him being mean to me
that's just it's funny and me acting as
if my feelings are hurt
is it's part of the comedy to like that
sells it alright so and I'm and I'm like
I wanted to give everyone the benefit of
doubt I didn't want to you know it
doesn't get to me as much as it does to
you so then at that point I didn't tap
into any frustration I was just like I
want to give them have benefited it out
and say now I don't have to tell you
that he's a character and that we just
made that choice but I do think there's
people out there who are issuing
complaints and who yeah think that but
you know and then you went into this bit
about well but do you do you like the
sympathy and I just felt you know I
think what was behind that is you're you
get you get more frustrated than I do
and I respect that
that because it's like well maybe you
should articulate it well what about it
frustrates you because I think it's a
valid frustration well I mean I think
there's a lot of things that fall under
this umbrella it's you know somebody not
getting the joke all right
always frustrates me somebody saying
again this is this is a I think when you
become when you don't get the joke it's
kind of like oh I'm a comedian and it
didn't work but then when the byproduct
is you're the bad guy it's kind of
frustrating when people like I mean P
our the mythical beasts aren't that rude
yet they like they need to take up for
me and they direct my rectum at you I
feel like the and again I mean I'm
probably generalizing right and I know
I'm not even though we know a lot of
mythical beasts like by name and like my
Twitter handle and that kind of thing
like I don't know and a bit individuals
come to mind so it's not like I have any
grudges against anybody but there it
seems to me in my mind what I've
constructed in my mind is that
there's a certain fan who's what they
like about us is just what they perceive
as the genuine rhettandlink but when it
comes to our comedy that we're actually
like when we're trying to be comedians
right and making comedic choices like
thoughtful comedic choices that are more
of an artistic approach that kind of
like I don't like that like they don't
like our local commercials like there's
a whole segment of people in fact one of
the reasons we stopped making our local
commercials is because we just couldn't
deal with so many people
misunderstanding what we were trying to
do comedic ly interestingly when we when
we hang out with like legitimate
comedians like professional comedians
the really a lot of times the only point
of reference they have from us is our
local commercials and so in our minds
from a comedic standpoint is those local
commercials that we made
that's a craft it's the potentially the
best work we've ever done but there's a
not an insignificant percentage of
mythical beasts who are like that's the
stupidest thing that you guys have ever
done and so that I don't I can't come up
with an analogy but it's almost just
like if you consider yourself to be an
artist and you're like my best work is
this thing and then this thing that I
kind of do incidentally that's the thing
that you're all connecting with and
you're not connecting with this thing
that I actually was really really
thoughtful and like is my best effort
and then I think it carries over to
again I think it's this taking us so
seriously as people that it's just like
well sometimes the bit between us as a
duo is that my character is going to
make fun of you and say mean things or
some other character in our universe
like cotton candy Randy's gonna say mean
things and then then I get tweets and I
see comments about what you gotta be so
mean to link and I'm like guys it's a
freaking joke and I think he Ronnie and
that just frustrates me yeah I I don't
you know I think you can anticipate that
ear biscuits is a much more real version
who we are
I'm not holding anything that you don't
already know so in this environment I I
think that I definitely make fun of you
a lot more here and there like the real
you that I do on the show because and
but there's it but we both know that
there's comedy in that here because
we're not just totally talking we're
making fun of each other because it's
it's funny but in the context of gmm so
much of the strength of show rides on
the impromptu honesty of the moments
like there's so many things that happen
that by design we don't know I think
we've talked about this before but there
are times when when we go into comedy
bits and there's and that balance shifts
from moment to moment like their entire
episodes that are planned like like when
you go into a conspiracy thing about how
Finland doesn't exist okay
bombshell can you please come clean
about what you think about Finland you
mean the country that doesn't exist as a
choice to make here do you really
believe it yeah and can you say it again
I think that way
I think that most people probably like I
would say that 19 there's definitely one
percent of the people watching who think
that I legitimately believe the
conspiracy theories and there's nothing
you don't believe what I believe that
Finland is a real country oh he did it
that was a big milestone no it's not
because and you kind of know you've
suspended your disbelief and we're going
into this bit and we like to do it does
it get the most views no but it's a
comedic choice you know I'm actually
making more craft work and I'm actually
like the band's I'm actually very
unlikely to believe conspiracy theories
in real life yeah you're making fun
you're like yeah I'm in it you probably
should have between your name and I'm an
extreme skeptic right and so I actually
find conspiracy theorists to be funny
like I find them funny well I mean so
interesting I think that they're an
in terms of a mode you look at the
Colbert Report not the show now but and
it's the transition is fascinating
because like that was that was brilliant
that's I mean there's a reason why I
think it won Emmys or should have and he
and he did because it was absolutely
brilliant what he did right and it
worked on it worked on a number of lives
how we how many things like what is the
Venn diagram of the people who don't
like cotton candy Randy who also don't
like Stephen Colbert I would say there
is a very high cross over that I know so
I think what you're getting at is I
think the frustration is that there are
there's our people in our in our GMM
audience who they and I think I
understand why they're like that they
want to take everything at face value
because they we present it that way I'm
you know I think that I think the reason
why I wanted to have this conversation
is if some of those people are listening
or watching that we can kind of educate
where we're coming from to free them up
to enjoy more of the entire breadth of
what GMM is and also to kind of
alleviate your frustration a little bit
I think that's kind of my my ulterior
motive in this thing you know there's
also this campaign complain about the
show being scripted which again is a
different thing but I think it's related
a little bit and I again we we go out of
we go in and out of scripted moments we
we shouldn't have to I think people are
so attached to the impromptu honesty of
the show that if there's anything that's
planned like I can tell that they have
thought about that joke ahead of time
it's like well we could be better at
delivering some jokes sometimes but in
the top of the show we plan out what
we're going to say so that we can get
into it quicker so we can just be more
succinct the you know they're just
different modes in the show that I think
I think it's an opportunity to make it
more fun to say okay I don't know
exactly what the I can't you could you
know it's all about since scene what
mode were working in and then saying you
know they could sometimes it kind of is
blurry and it kind of shifts and I think
that's a fun aspect to the
so I get frustrated when people
criticize when we're not just acting in
the 100 percent impromptu mode
you know the entire 100 percent
unplanned mode I won't say honest I'll
say unplanned because I do think there's
a different right and I and I probably
personally receive the brunt of that of
that complaint more simply because I
like if we're like if okay we've done we
did like fact-based games on GMM we did
it back and forth for a really long time
but those of you who've sort of observed
the patterns of GMM probably learned
that okay if we're gonna play a fad case
fact base game I host it and you play it
that's just what we've that's what we've
arrived at right and it's because we
each fit those roles better than the
other right and so it's like you not
having any clue as to what I'm going to
ask and what you're going to say set you
up to say really funny things funnier
things and I would be saying if I was
just set just thinking of things off the
top of my head mm-hmm
but I'm pretty good at saying jokes that
I've thought about ahead of time so yeah
and I think that yeah I don't know I
mean it's I definitely I don't sell a
lot of sit around thinking about this a
lot but there is this sort of underlying
thing that I just kind of understand
that there is some percentage I don't
know what it is people who kind of
perceive it perceive the show in that
way and then a lot of that is kind of
focused at me because I'm the one that's
the source of those things I might be
the source of more of this like scripted
jokes I might be a source of more than
negative like the negative energy when
it comes to the humor and so people who
are like I don't like that I don't like
anything that's negative I don't like
anything that's scripted it's just like
okay well I don't like what rep brings
to the show so I think I'm gonna talk
about those things I end up kind of
that's where the frustration comes from
and you know I think that we have such a
wide range in age that watches the show
there's a there's a level of maturity
required to start to parse the different
modes that we work in and get to the
point that I'm asking for which is that
it becomes something that you appreciate
and enjoy you know the question mark of
did that just happen you know I do think
that you know there's certain things
like when we're blindfolded or when
we're playing a game and we're not
supposed to know stuff I'll just go on
record and say that we don't we don't
cheat
I know Stevie cheated that one time was
a joke on us and you played the joke on
me with the with the pill which again
I'll get back to later but we don't we
don't cheat and and when it comes to
games and things like think yeah things
were the idea is that we're not in on
we're not in on it when we're not in on
it like on purpose like we keep things
from ourselves so that we can have
authentic reactions to the things that
we need to but I want to tell you a
story of a conversation I have with
Lando which like helped me I just came
to a realization about how he perceived
me how he perceived the show and then I
ended up talking to Lilly and Christy
about it I was I invited him on the show
to kick me in the balls when we were
doing the testing the jockstraps because
the plan was you were gonna get Shep to
kick you in the balls Lena was gonna
kick me and if you watch that episode
Shep ended up kicking both of us in the
balls cuz as I explained Lando said he
didn't want to do it and then in good
mythical more he did come on and he said
a little bit more about it but that that
night I was tucking him in bed and like
I got in bed with him and I was just
like hanging out beside him and like so
we could have more of a conversation it
was is one of those things where it's
like it's not your bedtime yet but go
ahead and get ready for bed that way
it's not because I want to go to bed
earlier too so we had a few minutes to
have a longer conversation than normal
and we were laying there and he said do
you still hurt
from getting hit this morning
meaning when Shepard hit me in the balls
now I mean he kicked me in the balls I
don't even know if all the times he
kicked me in the balls made the Edit
because he would kind of we had to cut
out the times when he would kind of miss
but like he gave me two direct hits and
I like crumpled over on the ground and
I'm like I gave anything on America's
Funniest Home Videos a run for their
money
because it was a direct hit my crotch is
lower to the ground than yours I don't
think he took that into account when
trying to say you're taller than me and
I'm I'm more of a man than you oh that's
what my crotch hangs lower okay it was
all crumpled up in a cup yeah it was
protected but then the cup hitting this
the sides of your what is that called
it's not the taint cause it's on the
right and left side yeah the rain in the
lane I don't right and left I don't
think we need that's where the ball
we're hit where the cup hits I don't
think we need an explanation I think
everybody understands so I mean it was
it was like the most sincere tender
question no pun intended
do you still hurt from when you got hit
today and I was like well it did hurt
but not as bad as I made it seem you
know I definitely wanted to tell him
that because I could tell how concerned
he was for me it was like super cute it
was also honest it did hurt but not as
bad as I made it seem and he said well
why would you make it hurt more than it
did and I said to be funny and he didn't
laugh he got this puzzled look on his
face and he's just kind of like he could
not he couldn't could not make sense of
it and I said I did it to make the show
funny and he said do you know what
bitcoin is ha ha ha I was like
like I'm not gonna sit here and explain
to you what bitcoin is it's your bedtime
like you're not that was the end of the
car I'm not gonna fall for it for this
trick and I was like so do you know what
it means do you know what bitcoin is and
he said no I was like do you he was like
do you know what bitcoin is I'm like
okay I guess I am falling for this I'm
like he doubted this I'm like I thought
first thing I was like well no not
really well yeah I mean it's it's
cryptocurrency and he was like oh so you
you do know what Bitcoin means and I was
like well yeah I I do he was like well
then why on your show did you keep
guessing Bitcoin for the answer to the
question and do you rent and I
remembered yeah we played a game where
we had to fill in the blank on something
and he was watching at home he wasn't
there that day and I kept writing in
Bitcoin as the answer yeah I don't know
what the game was I remember and I
remembered that when he asked me why did
I if I knew what Bitcoin was why would I
keep giving it as the answer for other
questions and I was like to be funny and
teaching him comedy I kid I could see
the wheels turning and I could tell I
was like wow my own son is realizing
that his dad is not as stupid as he
thought he was and I was like if he
would have understood this yesterday he
to kick me in the balls this morning so
that's what I should have explained to
it do you think you would have I think
so yeah now so so for the record it did
hurt it really hurt but I also took full
advantage of the comedic opportunity
presented to me to convey the fact that
it was shockingly painful oh it it was
Jacob just pointed out that was he was
in that episode it was the holiday list
he
was that kids he does watch yourself
he's not in it but he was physically
present there and that's why you
remembered the Bitcoin thing and he'd
been puzzling on it for all this time
so yeah I'm like dang you you must think
him you must think I'm kind of stupid
I'm not I'm yeah I'm not as stupid but
then I went out and I went I tucked him
in I was like so he went to sleep and
then I went into Lily's room to tell her
goodnight and I ended up telling her
what I just told you
probably in a truncated version there
were no sponsors involved and she was
laughing and I was like I mean do you
think I'm stupid and I'm like and I mean
I was I kind of really wanted to know I
was like well at what age do my kids
like start realizing I'm not stupid
and I ended up talking to her and
Christi about it and they it wasn't an
easy answer
I guess what very quickly one of the
things they brought it was well you know
dad remember when we watched that video
link struggling for seven minutes
straight from your solo you're so loud
mate he puts different hair on and then
he takes it off at this point and
realized and reveals Pam that I tweeted
because I thought it was so funny like
we're all laughing our heads off and
like I think I tweeted that like
Christie was like welcome to every day
of my life kind of thing
and I think there the point was that we
discuss was that well in some ways you
might be as stupid as you are
on the show and this is coming from the
people that love me the most and I guess
felt safe enough to tell me and they
knew watching that cut down and living
with me like Christie said welcome to my
life that it it's not like that all the
time but it's definitely like that some
of the time I mean I think that that's
in the and I was like well I got a
little defensive and I was like well
it's not that I'm stupid it's just that
I I can suspend my intelligence
Wow and I think that's what I'd well I
you know help you know if you're
watching a movie or something used to
spin your disbelief I suspend my
intelligence
I can disconnect the things that would
would stop me from saying things that I
just say on instinct or wielding sharp
objects in a way that no one has
business doing I can just turn that off
and say you know what this this is the
mode that I operate it well but I think
that stupid is the wrong word for those
things Amina so you're gonna come up
with a harsher word oh I mean I think
that like okay they're saying that
Chrissy probably probably deals with it
she would probably call you
absent-minded wait you know I'm saying I
asked her where stuff is that's in my
pocket all the time right which is not
stupid I mean like like there are n
Stein was probably absent-minded the
absent-minded professor is that stupid
but then things like the like when you
put the the cat I don't remember what
happened when you say like you spit you
drink water
what oh yeah oh that was the wrong end I
drink a drink at water through a thing
and then you watered your mouth back on
the thing yeah like that that's not it I
said I was at Mike intelligence was
suspended that's what you're saying for
that to me I don't think I don't think
that that's stupid I just think that
that is like an accident-prone cautious
lessly
impulsive yeah I don't know what the
word is but I just think it's it is you
are more likely to injure yourself with
a knife than I am but you're not gonna
injury and I have I have in real life I
mean I realize that I tell it isn't that
but it is a true story every time it
isn't like you could you can't actually
ever hold a knife it's just that no
because link is the one who's more
likely to do something with a knife
it's a funny bit that every time he has
a sharp object I'm going to take it from
him because that's taking something that
isn't untrue but then what
is kind of getting to the bigger
question that we're asking is taking
something that is based in truth and
exaggerating it for the sake of comedy
and that is I mean incidentally that's
what we do whenever we script something
like that's what we use no further the
second season a buddy system yeah it was
like three notches above that like it
isn't like in a thought exercise
alternate universe we don't we never
knew each other kind of way right and
it's just like it was extreme
caricatures right your character was an
extreme caricature of you in a way that
people may not even be able to follow
the logic to get to that point to
understand why we ended up even maybe
even more so with my character and like
the like weird like hippie stuff and the
man bun and all this stuff but all that
kind of came out of well I do cut I am
the one that kind of gets into some new
idea philosophy and like learns a lot
about and adopts it and suddenly starts
trying to tell you about it and that
kind of thing and so if I were to do
that unhinged unimpeded I might
eventually get to a place where I was
this weird dude who wore all this weird
these weird clothes and adopted this
weird religion like that you think
what's your question - my is link is
stupid in real life as he is on the show
like I elected to to frame it in the in
the harsh that harsh way I'll let you
come up with your own but what's your
what's your version of that question is
Rhett as blank in real life as he is on
the show yeah we're probably smart okay
pivot that is Rhett as self-absorbed
I don't think that that comes across in
the show I'm not gonna know it's like no
it's like there we try again what why I
don't think that's it what but no but
what I don't think that comes across in
the show well why do you have somebody
mad but let me explain though like like
a
know-it-all quality of like being
confident and cocky about being able to
do something like that's an element of
my my character but it's also an element
of whom of my personality that comes
from Who I am but no I am NOT I am NOT
that way in my interpersonal
interactions with normal everyday people
I'm that way when I'm in my comedic
element I I don't think that comes
across on the show I think it could come
across in real life at times but that's
not we're talking about I think it's
more of here's my pitch is Rhett just as
mean I think that's the criticism again
this is read as mean in real life as he
is on the show his link is stupid and
red is mean you know it's like that's
what you're saying that you get the
criticism that why you so mean the link
you know it's like yeah I would and I
don't I I mean that's not the right
warning well I mean I if okay if we go
down that path I would say that I would
think that no one that knows me no I
would say that if people who are my best
friends were to list my top ten negative
attributes I would be willing to bet a
significant amount of money that one of
those top ten would not be that I mean I
think that's I think that that is a that
I am NOT a mean person like that's not
I'm actually right I'm actually in my
estimation too nice of a person I've
talked about this before that I'm a I'm
a people pleaser and I'm like I laugh at
people's jokes when they're not funny
and I I you know I try to accommodate
people with who are being awkward and
stuff like that like that so I'm not I'm
not a mean person but I think in the
context of our characters and just arc
and also the context of us as maybe it's
just intensity I mean because I don't
think that mean is
I think you that's a criticism that's
leveled against you but I don't think
that's a character trait that's a
misinterpretation of what we've already
what the comedic bits that we've already
talked about but like an intensity it's
like you know the furrowed brow and the
I mean and you're not grumpy on the show
either so it's like maybe you're just
stupid to just go with that
are you as stupid in real life as I am
in the show I mean wish it what is your
estimation of it because I haven't I
haven't thought about this specifically
I think a lot about the fact that if
people were to just look at the two of
us and present ourselves on the internet
that they would be like Rhett seems kind
of red seems like he would just mean
isn't is is not the word that I would
use but if let's just go with that red
seems like he would be mean link seems
like you'd be really nice i I see yeah
and then and then of course my argument
is that well that's not true I also
think here's what I think it is I think
you are that you were much closer to
your true self on the show than I am I
think that there's more of that there's
more of a heightened thing with me with
my character on the show I think that's
maybe more the that's more my opinion
about it
yeah I think that and then when you go
against tight but I think that most of
the people who would characterize me as
mean on the show would probably
characterize me as mean Ryan rose that's
what I'm saying because they
misinterpret us again just being intense
seeing it there are some people who who
don't respond well to intensity at all
and like me and you me and you deal with
that right I like I get passionate and
intense about things and then people who
have more sensitive personality types
tend to take intensity personally yeah
and so would like me and you had to work
through that as we discuss things it's
just like you tend to be more focused on
like I'm not
lightness of something or like the the
correctness of something then the then
this it's like whether it's right or
wrong versus the way it's presented and
it's more like is it if is it are we
having a philosophical conversation are
we having a personal conversation right
and so and this is not I'm again this is
just part of my personality makeup this
is part of the personality makeup that
I'm addressing in therapy to one degree
because I'm very very much in my head
and spent a lot of time up here thinking
about things and then I don't translate
those things into feelings and they end
up kind of coming out sideways in
certain ways but I think that people I
think I'll speak about you first and
I'll speak about myself but I I think
that you harness the you know people
people resonate and might be more of a
fan of you than me if if the ideas and
the deliver the ideas resonate more you
know it's like I'm not going to give a
lot of not as much of ideas in the way
that you are I think that again when the
comedy comes mostly from your head it's
gonna have a certain flavor to it
that I think mine comes from a different
place that's why I stopped hosting the
episodes the the the fact-based episodes
because we've we find what our how our
makeup leads into our comedic strengths
so we're able to say in a room you know
you know what it would be better if I
never hosted another one of those cuz
Rhett you're so much better at it and
it's better for me not to know what's
happening and with this freewheeling
response we're hoping to capture
something mmm right and that's a good
that's the best of that we have both of
we have both of those things to
contribute and I don't know if I said
this on a podcast before but I remember
that you know it kind of felt like it
hurt at the moment where like it was
like it it was it felt like it was
emitting yeah I can't do that so I kind
of that's one less thing I can do I kind
of suck
you know it's like I you know as opposed
to and then I had to go through a
process of coming to grips with and
being secure in the strengths that I did
have to offer in and saying this is the
perfect way to to allow for that well
and to and to for both of us a platform
you like I said like I first of all once
we get going
in certain modes like both of us being
like reactive and in the moment really
work yeah yeah but it's not that I never
have ideas and it's not that you never
have right Valerius reaction if we have
to push right ourselves into a corner
and say okay well one of you if we're
gonna create a situation in where one
person knows what's happening and is
operating according to a plan and one
person doesn't know what's happening
who's going to flourish in those who
know about the pill and who's not right
and link is going to be funnier and
again that's that's kind of why I
thought that that was an example it's
not an example I know what you're saying
it's not an example of some clinical
care yeah we were not choosing but
you're gonna be comedic side you are
going to I didn't choose anything it was
a legitimate prank and I felt for you
are going to the wait the things that
you're going to say in that moment where
you're trying to convince yourself that
this thing works it's gonna be funnier
than what I'm gonna say like but I also
hidden out of 10 times I also don't
think that the chances of successfully
convincing you of that we're very low
and the chances of convincing me of it
we're also very high right if there's a
there's a high chance that in the midst
of that I would be like this is you this
is a prank and there's two to two
reasons well I think it's ultimately
just one reason I think it's because if
I begin to suspect that as a prank I'm
probably gonna point it out even if you
did begin to suspect it was a prank
you would suspend your intelligence yes
and go with this this bit
continue to carry it out whereas that's
just I don't have that in me I don't so
for the record I did not do that right
you if we got you we really got you and
that's when it's funny to ever watch
that one back yeah I would watch that
what and because it's not as funny when
you have to do it intentionally it's
funnier when it's actually you're right
authentic and that would be a hard thing
to do anyway but you know I I do feel
like oh but you know what though people
feel sorry for me and that's the thing
that I want I do want to address well
but before we get to that because I do
think this just to play into the the
question I knew that it would be funny
in the context of the show but if there
wasn't a camera there and I was just
like I'm gonna prank like I I do not
we don't prank each other like again
this is a little bit what's on screen
and what's in real life we don't prank
we don't prank each other we've never
pranked each other like it isn't in in
our makeup to be like I'm gonna take
time just for the hell of it - just
prank you at work just to see what the
reaction is and a lot of that has to do
with the fact that so much of what we do
is is it's a product that people can see
and so if we're gonna take the time to
do something like that to engineer
something well you you can bet that it's
going to be on online but it's also just
like that's just not that's not our
personalities it's not our personalities
to like find some way to like mess with
each other like that
and also if I were to do that if I were
to for some reason decide that I was
gonna prank you your reaction to a prank
that wasn't being filmed would be like
10% as entertaining as your reaction to
a prank if you were being filmed at you
knew it and it isn't because you're
acting it's just that when you're on and
when the cameras on I just don't have
that much energy you're in a mode where
you're like I'm reacting I'm processing
things out loud and that is a recipe for
entertainment and you know whereas if
you're just by yourself you just
we're both we're both rather boring
I mean if you know if you were to put a
hidden camera in our office and just see
what happens on a daily basis the way
that we work through creative problems
the conversations that we had you'd be
like this is I feel like I'm looking at
professor's office hours ha I got you I
got you
I've had a camera in our office for like
two years you can release it it'll be
very boring and it's so boring I got you
man you know the thing is I feel like
I've been I don't know I've been
thinking more about this like um it's
funny that you do 1500 episodes of a
show and you feel like there's nothing
you can learn and you're just on
autopilot but I don't think that's the
case at all I think that these are
things that I remember we used to get in
fights man like in Fuquay when we first
started doing Chia Lincoln like we'd be
telling stories and we wouldn't like I
wouldn't like a way that you said
something or you went and like how I cut
you off and it'll let you finish a story
or we would just it you know we had so
much to learn but there's the thing that
I'm learning now is I'm actually seen
and maybe this plays into people feeling
sorry for me because I don't want people
to feel sorry for me and say all links
the butt of the joke or everybody thinks
he's stupid or maybe he is stupid and I
feel sorry for him you know I don't I
don't want any of that because I I think
I've actually you know that the game
show thing is a good example but in
pretty much every episode I'm finding
out how the more of the true instincts
can be harnessed for comedy and so the
more honest I am it's kind of I mean and
I think I've been thinking about it more
since we talked about the Instagram
thing when you talked about dude if you
just do what you want to do on Instagram
like that you planning out something is
you're you're short-circuiting your own
comedic process so dance like nobody's
watching
anyway I actually think that in in the
exercise of doing that when in the
context of GM and understanding what I'm
trying to do that I'm just trying to sis
like thinking of it as spinning my
intelligence and knowing that like okay
I'm not an idiot I'm actually smart for
being able to harness just raw instinct
in this way yeah I actually feel better
about it but then a step further I
actually feel like that the show me is
kind of a gateway to me introducing some
of that back into my real life like I've
taken as an exercise to just say you
know what I'm going to I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go on instinct I'm gonna be
experiencing this moment I'm not gonna
overthink it I'm not going to be so
serious or given to my anxiety or
whatever maybe the what is instinctively
in my normal life the the first concern
that would enter my mind but then saying
you know what this is what it's like to
have fun you know I think the exercise
of doing the show builds the muscle of
being able to let loose a little bit and
then so in in the way that I play with
the kids or hang out with Kristi or like
when I get home from working like we're
all hanging out in the kitchen and it's
like oh we're playing music and you know
what I'm just gonna you know what let's
dance you know it's like we funneled so
much of that energy you know to your
point of like we're boring in into our
work that from a practical standpoint
it's maybe as if that's all drink I felt
like it's all been drained out of me so
I don't know maybe I'm getting a little
too you know I'm just trying to I'm
actually trying to harness that in my
everyday life to just become generally
stupider well I I think you know what
I'm I think what I was saying was that
people might expect that if I were to
just watch rhett and Link having a
conversation with each other then it
would be Halle it would be hilarious as
entertaining as an ear biscuit right
when in reality he would probably be as
entertaining as like the last half-hour
of this year biscuit yeah saying which
is it might be you might be like oh this
is the good stuff they got very real but
you probably don't laugh a whole lot in
the past 30 minutes I'm just I'm just
saying that that's how we kind of talk
to each other
I'm not nested for me for me I I mean I
feel like I I feel like I'm well I feel
like for me it's not a question of I'm
don't have enough personality left over
for my family a lot of times it's just
an energy question or a time question
because I'm gonna work on this thing
even though I'm at home well I got to
finish this thing and that's a problem
but that's not a that that's a different
problem that's like a time management
problem
I wasn't directing any of it at you but
I I will I I think that the moments
where we just embrace the sheer joy of
what happens on the show and we heighten
it I think is a skill that I was like
okay how does this how does how can this
cycle back ironically and the the life
can imitate art and I could benefit from
it it was just well it was an
interesting thought along the same lines
I don't know if you were in this
conversation with some of our close
friends we were talking about like I'm
you know I'm trying to figure out some
things with you know in therapy like
we've been talking about with like being
able to like understand what my emotions
are in deal with feelings and that kind
of thing but I think part of that is
like we we have we've got a friend group
and there's a very high emotional
intelligence in our in our friend group
like significantly higher than I have
sort of been close to for the majority
of my life
not judging you
just saying this in terms of yeah just
like greater friendships or whatever and
they're I mean they're all legitimately
just intelligent people but they're also
emotionally intelligent and and what I
mean by that is you get into like
somebody's going through something or
somebody shares something and they just
have just a level of insight and
perspective that you know I'm kind of
used to being like III like kind of
being the guy who knows things in the
room right you know that and annoys
annoys you and I understand that but
like I'm in a lot of places I am the guy
who knows things in the room right I'm
not an expert on anything but I know a
lot about a lot of things and so I tend
to feel like I've got something to
contribute but a lot of times with with
the group that we've gotten really close
with they're so emotionally intelligent
that I start to kind of feel like an
idiot and I'm like I don't I don't know
how to comfort this person I don't know
what to say in this situation because
that's not how my brain works I haven't
figured that out yet and so I'm just
gonna kind of be quiet
and I've also like done like a second
level of analysis again we've hinted at
the a Nia Graham and we will do an
episode about it at some point but again
it's the personality evaluation where
there's nine different personality types
I'm a three on the intagram which means
I'm a performer and achiever and one of
the things that the threes do is that if
they are not good at something they
don't do they don't play the game and so
engaging on an emotional level with
somebody is something I'm not good at so
I just don't do it because I do the
things that I can win at and that is a
and I didn't really really understand
that's how my personality worked until I
started reading more in depth about the
way 3s are and it's like if you they
don't have a good chance of winning the
game they do not participate and they
can actually be incredibly successful
because they are good at a lot of things
and they also only do the things there
so you see them and you're like and
they're good at all the things that they
do until you put them in an environment
where they have to behave differently so
the way this translates to the
difference between me on the show and me
and our life is that when I get into
those situations where I feel like it's
a it's a more intimate atmosphere I
become the quiet one we're on the show
there's no opportunity to be the quiet
one neither one of us is the quiet one
we both could talk a 100 miles an hour
we talk over each other constantly
because we both want to be the ones to
get the last word in like I think we
both suffer from that and that's one of
the things that contributes to why we do
what we do and we do it well and so the
thing I told I told our friends when I
was talking is like I actually think
that I my true self is more represented
in the context of what I do as an
entertainer than it is when I'm just in
real life like when I am my more you
know happy-go-lucky in the moment
reacting laughing trying to make people
laugh things that I do on the show and
even in the context of this I'm still on
a little bit yeah my on is actually
letting something out a truer connection
with Who I am
it isn't putting something on in fact
the mask and the facade is the quiet
reserved Rhett who is afraid to enter
into a certain situation for fear of not
being able to win that situation because
I frame it in the wrong way that's
exactly what I'm talking about I think
within yeah within the context of the
show you can have a you can experience
legitimate emotion within a certain a
subset of emotions right that are like
elation as an example what I think the a
surprise I'm unbelievably pain and
thankfully happiness we've created an
environment on the show where we can be
so comfortable because again this is the
thing that we didn't get when we did
like if you go back and watch the old
online nation clips right you look at
things like we were not
right it was the peak of the evidence
that there is out there of us not being
comfortable in an entertainment setting
yeah but this show and gmm also
represent these environments that we've
created and we've been able to
completely shape the environment so that
we can just be our true selves so it is
ironic that it seems like oh you're on
and you're acting but my theory and I
hear you saying the same thing is that
well actually that's that's who I am and
when I go out and I gate the real world
I turned that it isn't that I turn it on
when I'm on the show is that I turn it
off when I'm in real life yeah I think
that we've I my I I think my question to
the to the listener or to the to the
mythical beast watching GMM who
complains about things that maybe
they're just missing the comedy or
they're they're misinterpreting a
comedic choice as an honest moment and
then being disappointed and then being
critical of it I'm asking them to expand
the way they view our performance in the
show to to not shift but to include
those things I think that's what I'm
asking to them and I know that it
frustrates you a little more than it
does to me because it kind of as we've
discussed it goes to you but I think the
for you maybe there's an opportunity to
see you know I think you just described
the beauty of what the show the
opportunity it gives you as a person and
me as a person to like experience things
that can then inspire who we are in our
normal lives and those are the things
that people if they latch those true
moments if they latch onto them so hard
and make them so precious that they
can't take the the other comedic bits
you know it's like you can't fault them
for it because it's also a very it's
kind of the heart and soul of our show
because we've created an environment
where we're thick and so then to get
upset with them for being
for doing a character or doing a bit and
having a problem with it is yet yeah
that's kind of a meeting and I just want
to have my yeah taking it taking that
criticism as an and you can invert it as
a compliment that like the thing that
attracts them to the show is the heart
and soul of the show and it's the true
ice our true selves coming through and
they can't even take it when we make a
choice that deviates from it so I think
maybe that'll just help it just help you
process well I and also we taught about
this a little bit is I think that
unfortunately the people who have an
issue with these types of things are
also for whatever reason the personality
profile is they're more likely to engage
online and so the people who might
actually appreciate like and I think
ultimately we're we're different people
and I think better people because of
fielding that you know it's painful or
frustrating as it may be sometimes to so
I'll even go that far you need to be
thankful for I don't disagree with that
I'm just saying that one of the things
that makes it difficult is that I know
that there are people out there who
appreciate but you're gonna more like
you're more likely to get a comment
about something that they don't like
them that they don't they do like like
we get so many like when we when we meet
fans in meet and greet lines at shows
I've just I'm always surprised with how
many people have cotton candy branded
t-shirts on and say I love cotton candy
Randy and I'm like well why don't you
say something on the internet about it
you know it's like Monteux well do you
want to comment or do you wanted to buy
a shirt well how about both no but
you're right I again I don't I also
don't want to make it seem like I mean
I'm talking about these things because
you ask these questions so and I talked
about it the other day because it was in
the context of the conversation that we
were having I don't spend a significant
portion of my time like not even a I
don't even spend an insignificant
portion of my time like I spend barely
any time thinking about this particular
thing and being frustrated about it
I spend yeah we didn't talk
after that moment I spend the vast
majority of my time just trying to come
up with something to entertain and that
that's pretty much probably to a fault
that's what that's what I do with almost
all of my time so I don't I don't
I'm not sitting around stewing about any
of this stuff it's just if you bring it
up and make me start talking about it I
get a little frustrated about it but I
don't like sit around frustrated on a
regular basis about it so I don't want
anybody to think that so no need to
apologize to me if you've said things
and you're like oh I feel bad I said I
told Rhett he was mean I need to
apologize to him I don't need your
apologies so I mean I'm and I'm not
gonna be okay all right guys thank you
for hanging out with us and allowing us
to psychoanalyze ourselves and each
other let us know hashtag ear biscuits
whatever you want to let us know weigh
in on the conversation we appreciate
that tell people about this podcast so
they can listen to it how would you
describe it let us know hashtag it
Biscay describe it to a friend and then
tell us how you described it and tell us
what they said about it
that's good speak at you next week to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]